[Music]
you have four shows on television right
now four shows it like on purpose
I don't but you are in demand do you
take a lot of naps I mean how do you
avoid when do you sleep if you die do
one show and I'm tired you have four I
don't I don't get a lot of sleep but I
also I have fun where I can you know
what I mean I try and like recharge my
batteries wherever I can and my friends
Bonnie Burton and Anne Wheaton
introduced me to self adhesive googly
eyes and they vandalize stuff so every
once in a while just for fun I will
carry some googly eyes and just like
stick them on stuff in public places
like gas tanks or door not obscure it's
just really kind of hilarious to see
people see them and then they just sort
of smile about it sure's them up for a
second I know I know and it actually
comes in handy if I want to sneak naps
but still look busy check it check it
[Laughter]
[Applause]
70 have extras here you drew up
something I try some Andy here you got
gonna have a really satisfying this is
good here I gotta try this because this
is something I could use during
interview somehow no you cannot you got
to get your position just right though
or else it's completely detectable is
this working
[Applause]
I like any if you get yours on anyone
tuning in right now it's not gonna
understand what's going on
[Applause]
well people seem to prefer our show this
way yeah
then we're gonna do it like this from
now on good I mean that's totally that's
totally put this on I didn't have but
you gotta get like yeah they're not like
yeah I can stuff okay all right yeah
this is a good one too
that was so childish and one of the more
enjoyable things I have experience to
know why I gotta be honest I do a lot of
really adult stuff it's bringing them
you've done this for a while didn't you
bring you brought you brought a toys
what you went on I brought that that
first time that I came in yeah usually
several times you've brought toys on my
show but you went on Johnny Carson's
Tonight Show yeah you brought a toy when
you were a little kid I was yeah I was a
little kid I was in one of the most
awkward and embarrassing times in my
life - I was just going into junior high
really wanted to fit in at school I was
just whoa whoa foe missed it and it's
like aw if I dressed like them and I act
like they get my haircut then maybe they
will like me that that totally failed
but there's a record of it on the Johnny
Carson show which is me really trying
hard but I brought ectoplasm from the
Real Ghostbusters yeah yeah and brought
you brought slime ectoplasm on Johnny
Carson well night show even as a young
kid I was really into toy companies and
like finding ways to connect with them
and I went to the Toy Fair that year and
they gave me a bunch of this slime and I
was like oh man I'm totally taking this
on The Tonight Show and so I did I did
and johnny dumped it out on his desk and
then he threw it at Ed McMahon and Ed
McMahon threw it at him and I was like
chaos
let's take a look I think we have a
picture of that but just break the oh my
god look at you
yeah Spencer is that from that's my IOU
t-shirt of my coca-cola sweat pants a
look that never went out of style does
it go out of fashion I've been a fashion
maverick since I was a child yes yes dad
I got mention this dad's airs Tuesday
nights at 8:00 on Fox you're having fun
with it you having a good time oh my
gosh it's so much fun and it's um it's
in front of a live audience which is
like doing a play every week so but you
do it in four days we get the script and
then you rehearse it all week and then
you put it up in front of the audience
and they tell you whether or not it's
funny yeah hurry and a lot of times the
writers will will rush in and they'll be
like change this line do this line and
if we try that in the audience laughs
and whichever one is better that use it
so it's kind of like a thrill ride
except there's no consequences you you
you know what I mean
because you perform in front of the
audience and if you mess up they kind of
like that they almost appreciate seeing
they see they see that you're a human
being too they see well versus watching
it on TV they're actually experiencing
it you know in front of them so that's
been a really fun experience too someday
we're gonna get a live audience in there
instead of this recording we're using
tonight